Final Fantasy 7 had chocobo racing ten  had blitzball and 15 will have its own  extravagant minigame but you don't have  to wait to play it I'm Tony and this is  your Arkady gamespot news update in  Final Fantasy 15 noctis and the boys  play justice monsters five a game that's  part pinball part RPG it's playable  within the game but you can also  download it right now on iOS and Android  devices with a PC release on the way  it's a free download with available in  app purchases if that's your thing  justice monsters 5 plays like pinball  but with combat and special attacks and  recruitable monsters and if you play  before September 25th you learn special  rewards Final Fantasy 15 comes to ps4  and xbox one on November 29th if you  can't wait until then the tie-in movie  Kings glaive is now available on digital  platforms and in the meantime justice  monsters 5 seems like a fun diversion to  keep up with all the Final Fantasy news  you're already in the right place  you